[Music]
dude
who needs a lesson in titan slaying when
you can see the beyblade of the attack
on titan universe in action
yes i'm speaking of none other than levi
ackermann the shortest
man in parodies who has a strange fetish
of slicing things up while looking cool
with season 4 coming to a close
it's time to see 10 of the best levi
ackermann moments in attack on titan
but before i continue i'd like to
mention that i've teamed up with prime
video uk
to talk about some of the best anime
series that are currently included on
the prime video platform
to kickstart your journey with this
magical medium you can catch it on prime
video uk's youtube channel or click on
the link at the end of this video
taking our 10th spot is levi's
introduction in season 1. now we all
know how much character introductions
match you in anime especially in a
series like attack on titan let's admit
it season one was like the game of
thrones of anime you've got new
character faces popping up here and
there and then all of them being killed
off just like that so how do you make an
excellent first impression by showing
you stand at the top of the hierarchy in
terms
of power undoubtedly one can guess a
character stands at the top of the
hierarchy when he takes down three
titans without even breaking a sweat not
to mention he does this
in the coolest way possible levi
ackerman has this silent charisma that
makes your eyes get glued to his
character
it's that badass attitude complemented
by his silent and deadly demeanor that
makes his presence more visible compared
to other characters let's not also
forget this was the introduction of
humanity's strongest soldier
so it sure had to be impactful
coming up next is levi's final fight
with kenny now i've mentioned this
before and i'm repeating it again
levite was the main character in season
three yep ignore all that character
development of aaron and historia
because this season shined the spotlight
on levi's past and his greatest rival we
all know how cool those student mentor
fights are but the best way to make it
more interesting is to add guns
and then to add levi kenny the ripper
versus humanity's strongest soldier
what are the odds kenny may have the
upper hand mainly due to his skill with
guns but levi decides to be tactful here
using the explosion as a distraction he
directly slashes his mentor from his
sword and the ripper has to go running
back to the caves with a ripped shirt
not kenny's best day but then again that
man never had any good days
at number eight we have levi meeting
irwin how did you meet your best friend
on your way to class or perhaps knowing
you had similar interests in something
either way i'm sure you didn't get to
know each other after a frantic chase
inside a city and a fight with blades
leviathan
irwin's first meet-up is a rather
special one one of them was manipulating
the other person
and the other person being the smart guy
he is knew he was being manipulated and
acted along owen was the hyped up and
callous commander back in the day and
levite was like the street thug who
looked cool but laid back
unless someone called him for a fight
levi's goal here was to somehow get into
the military and irwin planned to find
the people who stole the maneuvering
equipment
after some air aerobics in a nice and
short fight scene the two destined
friends finally meet and who would have
thought that one of them would encourage
the other to give up his dreams and die
[Music]
speaking of friendship next up we have
the moment where levi had to choose
between
erwin and armin up until then levi
didn't have any challenging moments
because when you're the most overpowered
character in the entire show you can
always squeeze your way out of fights by
slashing and killing a couple of people
or titans in this case but now we have
friends in the equation
one squad mate and one commander who
would you choose okay let's shed some
light and see in the eyes of levi
your best friend or a random stranger
who worked with you for less than a year
levi almost chooses the former but levi
has to think twice when irwin himself
throws the serum away should he bring
irwin back into this nightmare again
irwin was a slave to freedom so should
levi put back the shackles his commander
undid
it's a tough spot where you need to
choose between your selfish feelings and
the feelings of others but in the end
what matters is that it was levi's
choice and he decided
not to bring irwin into the cruel world
again
[Music]
next up we have another one of levi's
entrances and that's his entrance in
season four honestly
this man really knows how to make
entrances if erin didn't make such a
grand entrance
in liberio levite would be dominating
all of the badass attack on titan
entrances list and can we take a moment
to appreciate how he appears when things
have turned upside down while the other
members are busy fighting levi's
chilling somewhere waiting for his turn
in the spotlight and then when things
turn sour
that's when he thinks okay it's time to
remind these people why i'm humanity's
strongest soldier
poco was an airhead who always abided by
the being a titan means being strong
and who's the best person to shatter his
perspective levi
zeke learned his lesson in season three
and poco learned his lesson in season
four when an ackerman's around always
check your surroundings because you
never know from where they're gonna hit
you
coming in at number five is levi's fight
with the female titan
one massive female going around stomping
soldiers and throwing them to the air
that's the female titan arc summed up in
just one sentence after seeing people
slaying titans for one whole arc and
then knowing our main characters are
titan himself that can make the concept
of man vs titan very boring but don't
fret marley has got some tricks under
their sleeve
oh is it isaiah being a genius again
either way this new titan is more agile
dangerous and slashes aaron's head with
the gymnastics better than a
professional athlete once again
who's there to save the day levi if
levi's good at two things
it's slashing things and rescuing
kidnapped people levi teaches the female
titan what it's like to mess with an
acumen and cuts us so hard that it
brings her to tears okay i know annie
didn't actually cry because of levi but
it sure must have given us some trauma
[Music]
next up is levi's famous god mode ak his
rage scene
after seeing his friend's death now in
all of these scenes we've spoken of so
far levi was still his usual calm and
collected self no matter how desperate
the situation was so if that was him
being a badass when he was normal and
calm
imagine how aggressive he could be if he
were in a rage turns out killing levi's
friends isn't the best way to have a
peaceful death after seeing furion and
isabelle's corpses
levi flies into a mad state of rage and
nearly skins the titan alive it's bloody
it's gory it's brutal but traumatizing
all at the same time with this scene we
were shown why levi was more
cold-hearted and numb when it came to
his squad's death he has seen death
before so it can never shake him again
as for the titan if levi's blades didn't
kill it the trauma surely would have
coming in at number three is levi and
zeke's fight in the forest
if one small [ __ ] looking man shows up
out of thin air and proceeds to slash
you apart that might mean you may not
want to mess with him again
but zeke having the so-called jaeger
jeans isn't the one to give up if he
can't handle the small guy alone then
it's time for some backup luckily this
man can call back up by serving wine and
then screaming so zeke has an army of
titans to support him within a matter of
seconds but remember he's fighting a man
who's the living personification of
numbness and trauma so just because you
turn his comrades into titans doesn't
mean he's gonna go soft on them once
again the same formula is repeated
zeke transforms his titan is butchered
he gets captured seriously these jaegers
need to learn their lesson messing with
an ackerman isn't going to give you a
happy ending
taking our second spot is levi's first
fight with kenny their second round
might have ended with ripped skin but
just like levi his mentor also knows how
to make a grand
entrance and kick things to the next
level it's no surprise he's an ackerman
after all with his squad to back him up
kenny corners levi on the rooftops and
then proceeds to chase him across the
rooftops it's not a pretty moment for
levi but we've got to see one of the
best choreographed scenes in recent
anime because of this chase i know mappa
is good but they can't be wit studio in
terms of fight choreography it's like a
living person with a camera moved along
with levi and decided to record his
escape in the best possible angles the
fight starts when levi jumps off a
rooftop and ends with him in a bar and
you've got juicy action to fill the
entire short trip hats off to the
animators for pulling off this scene
perfectly and hats off to levi for
escaping so many shooters with only just
a scratch on his head
[Applause]
okay actually let me correct the title
here it should be the famous
massacre of the beast titan it's one of
those scenes we like to call a fight
simply because there are two parties in
it but if you look at it from a
different perspective it's just levi
finding creative ways to cut down the
beast titan
arms legs eyes levi cuts all of these
one by one faster than one cuts their
birthday cake
zeke barely even has time to think or
even process what to do because this
devil of parodies is the living
embodiment
of speed mixing air aerobics with his
skill with the blades levi gives us one
of the best anime action sequences where
one man takes down a big giant ape with
absolutely no damage at all
trust me if irwin were alive to see this
he'd be grinning from a distance because
if marley's trump card are the titans
and paradise's trump card is the one and
only levi ackermann
so there goes 10 of our best levi akama
moments of all time
and the moral of this video is don't
mess with short people and if that short
man is an acumen that's all the more
reason to turn back and run
i hope you enjoyed this video and don't
forget to drop a like if you did don't
forget to check out our collaboration
with amazon prime uk
that's it for today anime fans and i'll
see you in the next video